hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Sean who's an
aspiring entrepreneur in the real estate
business and wants to write a bio for
himself that will help sell him to
clients and one of my advice and what to
do so Sean can grab someone to start up
a new company that's awesome the real
estate business is hyper competitive
tons of people in that market really
hard to stand out and people are often
over pitching themselves so they promise
things that you know Ben if they can't
necessarily deliver on and as a result
people don't really trust a lot of
people in the real estate business so it
can be really hard for you to stand out
if borrowing your shoes I take this
lightly different approach what I would
do is start with finding two or three
words that best describe the type of
person you are and some of your values
so think about maybe your friendly and
outgoing and compassionate or maybe your
you know hardworking or a warrior
negotiator whatever are the kind of key
words that best describe you and try to
put that into one sentence to start so
your your one sentence kind of quick
intro when you first meeting somebody
I'm Sean and I am the you know XYZ
whatever your sentence is and that will
help start to differentiate you and
you'll start to attract people who like
those values so there's tons of people
who want to get you know people in real
estate business and you want to be able
to attract the clients that will best be
suited to your nature so as an example
one of the things in my business is I
try to hire people who are nice I think
I'm a nice person and I like working
with nice people so in our job
description we always say we're looking
for people who are nice now some people
who look at that may think this is it's
really stupid to look for somebody who's
nice who says that and you know the
probably the people who are thinking
about that I don't want them working for
my business I want the guys who are nice
who see that same yeah I want to work
with other nice people too so if you can
come up with that kind of one sentence
that describes who you are with those
key characteristics then you'll attract
clients who want to work with that type
of person and it'll be a lot easier for
you to work with those people as well
because you have kind of
same values the next thing I would do is
try to get testimonials so instead of
writing a huge long bio a lot of it is
fluff right people really read those
things there's so many competitors again
going up against you so what I would
look at is trying to get testimonials
from people who know you and who've
worked with you in the past though you
said you're an inspiring entrepreneur so
I don't know if you have any clients yet
if not then get people who can talk to
those values that you've talked about so
you know if you're friendly and
hardworking as an example get people who
you know who can say how friendly and
hardworking you are so people can see
the stories of people who you've worked
with or people who know you then those
stories help sell how friendly and
hardworking you are as an example and
people gonna want to have to do business
with you I'd also try to get them to do
it on video if possible so you don't get
a get a camera go record some of these
guys it doesn't have to look
professional the more professional look
sometimes the less credible it is so you
want to look authentic get a camera
record some people saying you know how
great you are with those different
characteristics and I'd always include
that on my website and links to it and
all my marketing materials people can
quickly get an understanding of who you
are so Shaun I hope that helps that's
what I would do I know it's really tough
I'm gonna turn it over to my friend
Danny Amy from Falco marketing and he's
gonna share his thoughts on the question
as well
hi Sean thank you for your question the
best way to market yourself with a
company bhaiyya depends on your sales
cycle in other words when are people
going to read this company bio I'll give
you two separate examples in one example
you're gonna have a website people are
gonna find you on your website and the
company bio is one of the first
impressions that the audience will have
of you in another example you're an
offline networking business you're gonna
meet someone shake their hand give them
your card make an impression on them and
then they're gonna go to your website
and read your bio and those in both of
those cases the bio fits into a very
different role in the sales cycle so
that's the first thing you have to think
of what is your sales cycle look like if
it's on a website if the bio basically
has to do a lot of the selling for you
in the sense that it is the first
impression then think about what do you
have to present to first grab someone's
attention whereas if it's something that
they come into later in the sales cycle
when they're really just going to your
website to check up on you and see if
you're in legitimate if you're for real
then you want to focus more on
credibility building content like your
credentials and your successes your
experiences etc so I hope that helps you
I hope that gets you off to the right
start if you would like to tell me a
little more about what your business is
and write up a draft for me to give you
some feedback on you can find me at fire
for marketing comm I'd be very happy to
help you out thank you very much and
I'll see you all on the next video so
Sean I hope that was helpful I hope what
I said was useful and I hope what you
liked what Danny had to say as well good
luck writing the bio I know it's tough
to kind of get started and get those
first few clients if you need any extra
help feel free to shoot me an email with
with what you come up with for everybody
else if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below it helps me
make more of these videos and know you
guys like them and I'd also love to hear
what you have to say if you want to
leave a comment underneath and get a
conversation going so thank you and stay
tuned for the next episode
you